higher Island hi hi Mark welcome back
yes thank you for having me back nice to
see you again you as well who's your
friend so
this is my boyfriend Isaac hey Isaac how
are you nice to meet you nice to meet
you as well Mark
so is Isaac is not the kind of guy I
would picture you with no uh at all not
me either
I think so before we get into your
relationship with Isaac tell me what's
going on in your life things have
changed a bit for you right
the last time we talked I
think I've changed quite a lot
and I didn't really understand life and
what was really going on I think in my
own head I was very very depressed but I
started not drifting away from doing my
sex work only fans and all that stuff
but I wanted to realize what makes me
happy as a person and I decided like I
love art I've been doing art
since I was a kid and I was like I want
a tattoo I want to be a tattoo artist
like why can't I be a tattoo artist why
not like I did art for so long
I I want to be a tattoo artist so I got
my own machine from Amazon it was like a
crappy little machine like I would say
like six months ago now and I just
started practicing on people and then I
slowly just got pretty good at it and
then now I'm in my own private Tattoo
Studio and I tattoo full-time I mean I
still do only fans and I cam now and
stuff but tattooing is like what I found
makes my heart Happy it's wonderful yes
it's great you certainly have a
portfolio of work all over you yes I got
more since last time
what have you done since the last time I
saw you
tattoos somebody told me you slit your
tongue down them oh yeah
I didn't do that yeah
it was possible last time so yeah I got
my tongue split that was a big one like
I can use a few tricks that
so I did that and then eyes have been
the same and then I literally got these
tattoos under my face like
two two months ago I would say now it
says life and death because I think
those are the two most scariest things
in the world so I I just was like I
really want that on my face
and I did it you feel like
you have no regrets about doing any of
this work I have no regrets to this day
still about anything I've done like
everyone still says you're gonna regret
this you're gonna regret this I'm 23
about to be 24. I still don't regret
anything I've ever done and I just think
[Music]
even he's told me everything happens for
a reason everything's mapped out for you
in your life like everything that
happens is supposed to happen so yeah I
can't look back because looking back is
almost like regret so yeah no regrets
for me I think you probably enjoy
breaking down people's
um
assumptions about you oh I love it I I
love breaking it down when you know
people say I don't have a mom a dad or a
career like you know I'll pull them into
cameras and be like I'm literally normal
I have
all my family everyone is in my life I'm
I'm happy and I'm blessed to have a life
I have and I think
people are so focused on your visual
yeah treat they don't want to look on
the inside your parents but
I have a friend of mine picked you up at
the airport when you flew in from
Houston and
she was telling me how you're you're the
you're the exact opposite of who you
appear to be or who you assume you would
be exactly yeah she said that she was
like I would expect a switch between
y'all like you would be the crazy one
and he would be like all team but no
it's it's totally opposite yeah you're
you're a very sweet person I think once
yes you get past the exterior yes I
think so I was talking with Isaac before
you before we started and I said I asked
him like so what do you see in a Ryland
and they you know so I'll ask you that
again on camera what is it you see in
Rhode Island I think the first thing
truly was just like the individualism of
her I know it takes like a lot of
confidence to
change yourself like that
um I just find it like beautiful because
it's like one it was like you had to put
thought behind it it couldn't just be
done overnight there's a lot of
Aftercare that goes on with like tattoos
and the tongue splitting and stuff so
it's like a responsible thing that has
to be done it's like when immediately
when I first saw her it was more of like
I just got straight to the questions of
like what the [__] did you do and then I
think the conversation between US just
went back and forth so naturally like
she was answering the questions because
she realized I was just curious
uh we met at a bar
uh downtown in Houston yeah downtown
Houston it just so happened to be like
in the oldest elevator
uh second oldest elevator in Texas yeah
they're doing like a comedy show or
something and we were trying to sneak
away from it and that was like the only
area and they were in there at first and
I just like slammed my way in and then
it was either deal with the comedy or
stats so I forced that it's just so
weird though because we weren't even
supposed to meet like the only reason we
met is because I was tattooing my friend
and she was hungry and I was like let me
finish your tattoo you can eat after
she's like no come eat with me please
and then we went to eat at this
underground Food Hall place in downtown
Houston and then after that she was like
can we go get a drink and I was like oh
I don't really want to but we did and it
was the bar that he was in and then she
knew him I didn't know that like they
knew each other like mutually and he
just came in the elevator when we were
sitting there and then we just stayed
with each other all night and we haven't
left each other's side since and that
was like six months ago six months ago
yeah I mean it's interesting I think
Isaac sees through your exterior yeah
into who you really are yeah
yeah I even asked him last night I was
like why do you love me like she's asked
me a couple of times and I think every
time it's just a little more reassurance
that
maybe she finds it hard to believe but I
don't really find it that hard to
believe
I think it's like the same way that she
said like if you looked at her you would
assume that she was some way if you
looked at me you would assume I was some
way but they're actually quite flipped
like when she says she has her like she
still has her family and stuff like that
you would assume she wouldn't but on me
you might assume I did which is opposite
yeah so I think like everything is kind
of like a counterbalance it's like look
people look at you like this you have to
understand there actually is people like
this so you can't really just come one
way about it or be defensive or this or
that like you have to be able to engulf
everybody's point of view on it how old
are you Isaac I'm 30. you're 30. you
seem like a good Texas it's pretty
straight yeah born and raised yes Texas
boy
but uh you're able to see past all the
oh yeah for sure
for sure visual stuff and you know some
people are into that yeah that you're
um
reference I don't think it would be like
a preference I think anybody that I've
ever dated before that had tattoos or
more of like a normal tattoos arms legs
you know chest areas
um but it's never been something like
I've been like oh I only like tattooed
girls but like
I don't think it was anything other than
just her
like just her being her because I don't
think anybody else could really pull it
off right no when Ariana told me she had
a boyfriend I was picturing my
imagination was turning him into
whatever I thought he would be I didn't
know if I would meet you or not so then
you walked in I'm like that's not you
look like my bro my brother you know you
don't look like what I would picture her
with wow but I think it's beautiful
because you guys see through the who
each other maybe really is yeah like
typically he wouldn't even be like my
type like he's really not I've never
dated a white guy in my life was that
right yeah I never have it's usually
like Hispanic man and stuff but that was
always it was always toxic and not good
for me but like
he just had something about him and like
I I just find him so attractive and not
just attracted just he's helped me so
much mentally like when we met I was
still in my depression and I I wasn't
showering that much I wasn't changing my
clothes I didn't care about anything I
just got into this really bad depression
and he like helped me get out of it
is a depression
subsided a bit since you've been with
Isaac I would say so when we first
started
getting together I was having bad panic
attack like we kind of never went
through that like cute little puppy
stage it was kind of just like right
forward and like we moved in together
like month one so it's like he kind of
got all my bad sides at once basically
like yeah the first night was cute and
fun and like we had so much fun but then
like the real thing set in and I would
have panic attacks every day and I
couldn't breathe and like he would have
to be there and like I wouldn't care to
shower change my clothes or anything
like he stepped in and helped with that
and then I got on medication and I I
take Zoloft and Klonopin for the anxiety
I mean it helps a little bit but more so
just him being with me and being my
partner and like we have two dogs and
two cats together so it's like we're
like a family yeah I think that's helped
my depression so much like I lived in a
big town home alone just by myself like
what am I doing with my life like I'm
alone I have no one like what is my life
because people you know think oh I'm
orylin I have this I have that but
that's like far from the truth like I
just sit at home with my cats like what
are the the biggest misconceptions
people have about you
that
I'm a drug addict that I don't have a
job that I don't make any money I don't
have life like I don't have like it's
like all of them you're a total freak
yeah that like what what is wrong with
her and I'm like
what like and it's just like the like
people are like imagine when you're like
50 or 60 and I'm like okay imagine when
you're 50 or 60 you're both gonna be the
same I'm just gonna look cooler than you
you know like
it's just fresh like we're in 2023 like
it just frustrates me like grow up like
how can't you see Pat I get I get so
heated because it's just like how can't
you see past that and it's like you know
I started my own YouTube channel and
everything so it's like I get my word
out there now like I I want to break
down those stereotypes through that and
realize like it's okay that you have
tattoos piercing like it doesn't change
the person you are like the pictures
last time now we saw of me with no
tattoos I'm Still That Girl and even
um
the girl who picked us up she even said
like you look like a little cheerleader
girl like I see the girl
that you used to be still even with all
this because as soon as I open my mouth
and talk like people realize I'm not
this crazy like obnoxious drug addict or
homeless or whatever I'm like and I'm
still that person it's just this is what
fulfills my life like I had to do this
to find me
it's interesting so you've pulled back
from stripping yeah I I quit stripping
uh last year there was just no money to
be made in it anymore like literally I
would go in and make 50 60 and I had to
cover up all my face tattoos still and I
was just like this is not worth it I'm
not happy I'm busting my knees up like
I'm barely making two three hundred
dollars a night to get like groped by
people and it's like a full nude club so
I was just like I'm done with this like
I have more respect for myself and even
this year I thought about going back to
the club but I was like no I don't have
to do that I can push myself harder like
on doing my tattoos I'm you know going
harder on my only fans pages and like I
recently got into canning so
only fans in caming is still
sex work yeah it's still sex work how
does that affect you emotionally
me or him you oh
um
I I can imagine how it affects Isaac
yeah it's just
I
it's not that I hate it I don't hate it
um because without that I would not be
where I am today like I'm already about
to open a bigger Tattoo Studio because
of that so I respect it do I want to do
it forever no do I want to like
coach people and help them and maybe
doing that will help them get out of
that situation into a better one of
course like so my emotions with it I'm
I'm content with it I'm not gonna say oh
my God it's like I love doing this every
day like no sex work is hard like it's
mentally hard but like
it's harder without a partner like when
he stepped in the picture it just helped
it so much like he helps me with it even
like not not in my videos or anything
but he just helps me on like my days out
I'm like I feel like I can't even do
this work and he just helps me realize
like it's gonna get us to a bigger
picture one day and it's just gonna be
better
oh yeah what do you do uh mainly right
now art
uh just in different mediums of t-shirts
more cut and sew taking things from like
vintage shops and repurposing them to
just give it a new life
and they call it like upcycling yeah
yeah yeah but
um in Houston it's not such a big Market
there's a lot of textile out there with
the industry it's just like a good thing
to have
going out there
and with only fans you have very little
one-on-one with your audience right
no
or do you no I do I I like everyone on
there it's almost like I have
a little relationship with each person
or my only fans like nowadays girls and
their only fans have Bots and people
that they don't even touch the early
fans they pay people to manage their
only fans and they just make nude
pictures and stuff like I don't do that
like personally for me that's wrong I I
view this even me is like like I'm a
counselor in a way and I'm helping
people in a different type of way so
that's what makes me happy because there
are people that have come and said I'm
not even looking at your page I just
I've watched your YouTube videos and I
just think you're an inspiring personal
it took me like a hundred dollars yeah I
would think you have a large part of
your audience that are just fascinated
with who you are yeah they are like they
just like they're just like well she
doesn't have a GoFundMe or anything this
and that well I'm gonna go support her
only fans and like I I contact with them
like I have conversations with them long
ones sometimes it's like you know so it
feels good in that aspect like to me if
I had like a bot doing it I was just
like I'm not doing my job right like if
I do a job I want to do it good just how
I'm tattooing I started tattooing on a
floor like a dirty floor just doing
whatever and now I'm in a really great
Studio like any job I do I want to do it
right so yeah I would say it is like
pretty connecting but no I'm not like
meeting up with anybody or doing any of
that but what I find most interesting
about you is that you you who you are
inside is almost the exact opposite of
who you are on the outside yeah
it's yeah exactly and even sometimes I
question to myself like
I really did this to myself
do you have moments where you yeah
there's moments sometimes I wake up and
I'm like God my whole face yeah I'm like
it's like not even a regret it's just
like
almost a happiness of
what I had to go through in life to
learn things because I feel like if I
didn't do this to myself
I wouldn't have learned things like I
wouldn't have gotten
in my journey to to this I mean living
in that body yeah the reaction you get
from from Outsiders strangers yeah must
be very unique so what have you learned
about human beings from
honestly wearing this body a lot of them
a lot of people are evil online honestly
like
through Tick Tock I go live on a lot of
things where I just like to talk and I
like to tattoo people on my live streams
and it's like I like to connect with
people and people are like oh my God
you're so ugly you're disgusting like
people are really evil like but I bet
they wouldn't say to my face because
I've really never had one person come up
to me and like really just say you I
always get ugly stairs but I stare back
like I don't care but a lot of people
like do give positive feedback and they
see me in person and they're like oh my
God your tattoos are so cool so a lot
are sweet but a lot of people are just
really sad with themselves I think so
they want to bring it out on me or
they're mad that they can't do this and
be successful like me people get mad at
what they don't understand I think yep I
think you're exactly right there
social media gives them a platform to
just say whatever they want with no
repercussions at all no
no it doesn't affect me in any type of
way I'm still gonna do this like people
hate on me I still split my tongue I
still got tattoos on my cheeks I don't
care I'm gonna do what makes me happy
and those people that hate should do
what makes them happy so they can stop
hating on other people what is going
through your head when you're deciding
to split your tongue or when you're
deciding to get even more face tattoos
or make your eyes black it's like an
urge it's like this thing in my head
it's like you know people get a high for
drugs that's not where I find it I
really I don't do any drugs or anything
like that so I feel I get my fix or my
my next step in life almost it's like
every tattoo or everything I get is like
the next step in life for me so it's
like the tongue was like I can't have a
normal tongue anymore it just popped
into my head I was like my tongue has to
be split like I really just thought that
in my head or I can't keep going forward
with my life does it impede your ability
to eat food or talk not at all it at
first it was so bad it was the most
painful thing I ever did in my life I
regret it like I regret that like I
regret the pain of it it was the worst
pain I've never I didn't sleep for four
days I couldn't eat for like five six
days
um I had stitches in my tongue like the
top of my tongue was rotting off like I
I like the Journey of it I guess so like
sometimes pain is therapy
yeah
what do you make of all that
it's wild
um yeah
that's just like a personal thing like
you said like that's something that she
couldn't move forward with and then
that's all I have to know about anything
about is like if that's what she needed
then that's what she needed and it
doesn't do like you said it doesn't
change how I eat it doesn't change how
my tongue feels so I I don't give a [__]
what she does with her tongue but if it
makes her feel more like her then I'm
like right there behind it yeah and it's
like I still have body dysmia like I
just got it's weird though like the way
that it moves is weird yeah like
sometimes you'll see it like
she has control of it yeah it's like
normal people when they lick their lips
they go from like one side to the other
like she'll start from the middle and
it's like windshield wipers that like
have like because I can't do it all once
I'm just it's like really like a
chameleon you wouldn't think that when
you split a tongue like it really gets
like that motion like you think it'd be
kind of dead and numb but like it's
weird you can pick stuff up yeah
like now people are like oh my God your
eyes and I'm like oh yeah and then I
just like do this with my tongue and
they're like they freak out even more
I'm just like yeah they can taste
differently yeah like if I have a Coke
and a Sprite I can taste both of them at
the same time
I blindfolded she can let you know which
side the coke is on yeah
for the children think of you oof small
children there are some small children
that are like oh my God mommy is
superhero and then there are some that
are like trying to start crying start
crying just staring at me heavy like but
they're kids yeah it doesn't faze me
I still have like body dysmorphia though
in a sense I guess
um like I got my boobs bigger recently
uh and then I'm getting liposuction and
like
six days so it's like yes the tattoos
made me happy but
I'm I want to be happier with my full
appearance because I feel like when I'm
at my full potential and I'm happiest
with myself then I'll just really
flourish even more
so the tattoos make me happy and stuff
but you know I still have problems on
the inside I have to fix like
it's it's like a bandage almost it's
just it doesn't fix what's inside
but it helps me move on in life and keep
going with okay I did this no I have to
keep going what's the next thing
what are your goals long term
long term it's like I feel like I really
didn't know at first but now it's like I
have all these ideas in my head like we
want to own well we're already working
on it but uh getting a huge Studio he's
gonna put his clothing brand inside of
it um I'm gonna own half of it and it's
gonna be a tattoo shop
so we want to have a clothing studio and
a tattoo shop and I'm going to have a
bunch of artists in there and then we
want to expand that and maybe get a
tattoo shop in Colorado and keep going
with that maybe airbnbs we're already
like just thinking about like he's so
smart with this stuff like I wouldn't
have thought of half of this of these
things so like that's where the goal is
now we want to own like a bunch of
virtual properties and the goal is to
get a house this year hopefully for
ourselves
and yeah just keep going with our lives
and seeing where it takes us but that's
kind of where it is right now like the
goal is owning a tattoo like shop that
we can rent out to other people you have
to deal with sometimes scaring people
that you come like let's say you're
renting out a room to somebody through
an Airbnb
and they meet you
some people are going to be freaked out
that's what I'm for yeah he's foreign
yeah because I mean even at that like
you know when renting or buying a house
or anything people just assume I don't
have money I don't have anything that's
like I don't care about money money
doesn't make me happy sure I have some
money but
that doesn't matter and it shouldn't
define a person and it's just like
people just automatically assume I have
nothing and this and that so it's like
people don't think I could buy a house
so it's like it's kind of scary
sometimes like that I could get rejected
even though I have the money just
because the way I look because I can't
trust me per se
like you know so that's like the only
downfall I think
that's why he's here he's got the pretty
face for it yeah but this all started
with just the common understanding that
she obviously doesn't want to do sex
work forever
so then we just started pulling out what
would make her happy
forever if she was doing that as work
the tattoos would make her happy
traveling would make her happy so we've
just been piddling around with ideas of
like what can you do and still move
around and still make your money and
still do this and be able to
kind of get away from the sex work
completely because like she said even
though it is beneficial for her in some
ways it is also takes a toll on her in a
lot of other ways
um it kind of
it doesn't really like I guess it's just
like that my personality it's like
whenever we met I think if she would
have acted
more
what's the word like flamboyant about it
and just being like I'm an only fans
this and that and that and that like it
would have kind of turned me off to it
but like the conversation we were having
about like tattoos and this kind of
stuff like after that first initial
conversation it didn't really matter
what she did so
obviously like when we got into it it
was something that we had to talk about
and it was like how do you feel about
this or how do you feel about this and I
don't think she's ever had anybody that
was understanding of her situation so
it's like we do things together we talk
about things together like we've
dedicated areas in our house to that
specific so if you're going to be doing
this like I'll leave you alone in like I
don't have to know about it we'll never
have to see that you know
um but then I also help her out with
things like setting up you know photo
shoots or different kind of things for
like this for helping with promotion
just to help her to get out of the only
fans bubble because that's initially
what she wants to do you're not having
actual contact with guys no uh I it's
just yeah I I I've even told guys you
know like I I can't do it I've realized
I started meditating also and
he's been such a support he built me
like a meditation room and a sex work
room for so I need I started meditating
and it helped change a lot of things and
then you know
he built that like he's so supportive he
built that room for me like like he
knows what I'm doing down there he knows
I'm FaceTiming guys like he knows what
I'm doing he knows I'm playing with
myself on a camera and he's still
supportive in there for me a lot of
people wouldn't be
you know so there's no contact with guys
but a lot of guys don't even need that I
realize that they just need someone to
talk to
like really like it's like I'm a
counselor sometimes like they just want
someone to talk to like even a guy came
on
like cam soda thing one day when I was
streaming and he just wanted a tattoo
for me and he didn't know how where my
stuff was he I just popped up on the
page and then you just want to get a
tattoo for me like some people don't
even care about that stuff
because people really just hear me talk
even on YouTube and they like not fall
in love with me but just the aspect of
who I am and like dang I would really
like to talk to her
so it's like they don't if they respect
me they would realize I don't need to
meet up with someone for four or five
hundred dollars you know like not
knocking that because that's what I did
in my old life but it's just like to
move on I can't have those energies in
me anymore like every time you're with
someone you're putting your energy into
them and I used to not really realize
that and wondered why I was so messed up
in the head when I was like you know
basically prostituting myself and
wondering why I'm so messed up when I
was letting all these energies enter me
and yeah when I stopped that it kind of
just like flourished and
it's just my head's more clear now of
what I want to do with my life you know
maybe I'll do only fans for another like
three four years I won't be mad about it
if it gets us to my goals and our dreams
what we want in life but no I'm not
gonna I don't want to be doing it 40 50
years old we want we want like five
tattoo studios like throughout the
country
maybe even more like the possibilities
are endless
whatever you want to do yeah
and Rylan what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned from
this life
with all your tattoos and piercings and
maybe it's changed since the last time
we talked but
I would just say
just make sure you're happy no matter
what you're doing make sure you're doing
it and you're happy with yourself and
you love yourself like
you need to have self-love to live in
this life I I don't I don't know how
people maneuver without it because I
remember when that was me and I would
just say love yourself and love others
like I still haven't changed my motto I
say peace and love every time I can
because that's what the world should be
so that's just kind of how I view things
like everyone just should just be good
to each other like
my life lesson is just be kind like
literally just be kind to people be kind
to yourself that's the most important
thing
all right Rylan Isaac thank you so much
for coming thank you thank you
good luck with everything you guys are
doing thank you thanks